[Music]
what's the first thing you would do if
you were the president I would stop
worldwide a nationwide prostitution and
I'd help feminists get their points
across
I would campaign finance reform because
I think there's too much money in
politics and that makes there's an
influence an unbalanced influence with
people with money and I don't think the
general masses has as much say the very
first thing I would do is hire my
cabinet because I couldn't do it alone I
would try to find all the leading people
in each industry and get their advice if
not being the secretaries of the cabinet
but get their advice on who I should
hire for the position so I don't know
everything I need the people who know
the the most about the positions to be
helping me hire them first thing I would
do is focus on infrastructure why
because input because to have a strong
nation we have to have strong
infrastructures good education and
basically fix the nation because if we
don't fix the nation from down under
then we'll not have a strong nation
bring peace how did you do that by being
peaceful
make sure all children are able to
access all the human rights should like
elicit this vineya vineya
like a solo female if I was president
right now I would immediately increase
education funding to because the basic
basis of a Democratic Republic is an
educated public I would try to
depoliticize economics I think the
economy is one of the most like integral
pinnacle facets of this country or any
nation in general and so finding a way
to get conservative conservative and
liberal economists together to kind of
like educate and create this like
bulletproof plan of how to get our
country out of the rut that it's in I
think when our economy stable social
things cultural things political things
are on more of like a level playing
field I'd also like go out there and
talk to the people like you can't have a
president that doesn't you don't feel
like you can connect to and I think that
the current president right now it
doesn't feel like I can go and like stay
with him and have a cup of coffee like I
want people to feel that way as well
like why they're barricades in front of
a sense that's already there you know
and I don't think that's something that
people felt as strongly with Obama so
those are two things I would do a lot of
other things but yeah if I was president
I would throw a big party at that place
I'm I should tear down that fence first
so people get in but yeah there was a
party I'll probably try to fix taxes me
know wage you know I'm playing with rate
you know change all that and also their
homelessness that's part the first
application
eliminate as much greed as I could from
my power base of course that would only
take care of the United States because
I'd only be the President of the United
States I'm like the guy across the
street who thinks that he is the leader
of the planet who can tell other
countries where their embassies will be
where their capital will be he believes
that he can spend the Mexican people's
tax budget and building a wall he is
only the president of the United States
and I would only be the President of the
United States and I would take care of
the children here first and our senior
programs here first instead of the
funding of so many countries but there
would still be funding for third world
nations but not for g20 nations so
eliminate the breed
I would put back the American Embassy in
Tel Aviv and take it off of Jerusalem
the tax reform I will change it
eliminate it so it doesn't affect my
country I think because the taxes are
too tough for pro Rico people
as president I would arrest the current
president Donald Trump for treason and
crimes against the United States if I
was in there right now let's say I'm
sorry everybody that we had this whole
everything up we'll try to do better I
would address the American people and
suggest to them that they need to start
working together from both sides
Democrats and Republicans and stop the
bickering stop fighting with each other
start working together towards solutions
that are good for all the American
people free health care for all free
education for all college education as
well and yeah affordable housing
affordable everything really I mean like
people should be able to live in this
country not die like they're doing now
not repeal Obamacare and why is that
because that's a health care policy
that's there for everyone out there and
at the best price that everyone can
afford health care and that's how it
should be affordable to everyone if I'm
the first in the United States the first
thing I will do it makes you our issue
all the children no medical care no
medical fee for free they don't have to
pay and all the senior citizen they
don't pay anything nothing is for free
and then the people they are qualified
to be the good student has to be a good
student they don't have to pay anything
when they go to college I make a circle
whatever home whether the homeless
people especially homeless veterans
that's very important
the first thing I would do if I was a
president is I would address the whole
entire country for multiple hours in a
well-written speech about unity because
I think there's a lot of stuff going on
that is just silly and doesn't need to
exist and I think it would take a great
ongoing and well-written speech to fully
explain what's going on in the country
and make sure everybody comes together
as one because that's all we need to do
in this country to come together as one
that's what I would do
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Raya and I'm
the owner of this channel I'm also the
person behind the camera and I thought
I'd take a minute to thank all the
subscribers I gained so far and maybe
ask the new years to hit the subscribe
button if you liked this episode or if
you're a fan of my channel in general I
mean a lot thank you